[Musica]
come hanno fatto alcuni musicisti con
dei limiti oggettivi a diventare delle
grandi rockstar come sono riusciti a
raggiungere il successo nonostante
alcuni elementi remassero loro contro
prendiamo ad esempio il caso di rick
allen il batterista dei def leppard
senza un braccio o gary numan famosa
icona new wave anni 80 affetta dalla
sindrome di asperger
oppure gli u2 una delle più grandi rock
band di tutti i tempi e all'inizio della
loro carriera avevano degli oggettivi
limiti tecnici avevano concorrenti molto
più virtuosi di loro allora come ci sono
riusciti c'è un elemento che li accomuna
io suono il pianoforte da quando sono
piccoli non avevo 8 anni me lo ricordo i
miei amici andavano a giocare a pallone
io ripetevo beethoven e chopin e la
musica in particolare rocca sempre fatto
parte della mia vita mi ha donato
tantissime emozioni e anche un punto di
vista completamente differente col quale
affrontare e superare le mie sfida
allora ho capito che le rockstar che
vanno al di là dei loro limiti hanno un
elemento in comune che si tratti di rick
allen e di gary numan degli u2
queste persone pensano ed agiscono in un
modo completamente differente quasi
all'opposto rispetto alle altre allora
ho tracciato delle analogie tra il rock
e la vita lavorativa e personale ed ho
capito che quando si tratta di andare
oltre ogni limite entra in gioco un
elemento fondamentale
io lo chiamo focus potenziante le
rockstar ignorano quello che non hanno
si concentrano su quello che hanno
ignorano quello di cui non hanno il
controllo e si concentrano solo su
quello di cui hanno in controllo questo
potente cambio di prospettiva permette
ad alcune persone le rockstar e ad
alcuni piccoli gruppi di persone le rock
band di andare oltre ogni limite
ognuno di noi nasce con dei
condizionamenti più o meno forti più o
meno invalidanti
c'è ad esempio chi nasce con il fisico
segnato dalla genetica oppure da un
incidente traumatico avvenuto nel corso
della loro vita
c'è chi nasce all'interno di contesti
sociali economici e razziali
particolarmente complessi
eppure c'è chi per motivi politici
religiosi razziali o di guerre alla vita
segnata fin dall'inizio
allora ci dovremmo chiedere come fanno
queste persone ad andare avanti
qual è la loro motivazione qual è il
loro dialogo interno quando siamo
all'interno di alcuni meccanismi
complessi e molto difficile per venirne
fuori è la maggior parte delle persone
spengono sogni e desideri ma a parità di
contesto difficoltà ai limiti ci sono
alcune persone che quei sogni quei
desideri di accendono vi faccio un
esempio è la notte del 31 dicembre 1984
per i cullen e alla guida della sua
automobile di fianco a la sua fidanzata
per una sciocca gara automobilistica la
sua auto va fuori strada hanno un
incidente
la ragazza è quasi incolume lui viene
sbattuto fuori dall'auto veicolo più
tardi dichiarerà di essersi svegliato in
un campo ma il suo braccio era rimasto
nell'auto veicolo ricca ha solo 21 anni
suona nella sua band i def leppard sono
una band heavy metal
da quando ne ha 15 dfl parte sono la sua
famiglia
livi meta della sua vita seri che fosse
stata una persona come le altre
probabilmente il suo dialogo interno
sarebbe stato qualcosa del tipo come
faccio a suonare la batteria in una band
heavy metal senza un braccio
maric non è una persona come le altre ha
reagito ha reagito diversamente si è
concentrato su quello che aveva su
quello di cui aveva il controllo si è
fatto aiutare dal suo amico cantante da
un altro amico batterista quello degli
status quo ha scelto un'azienda
specializzata e hanno costruito insieme
una batteria specifica che tenesse conto
solo dei tre arti rimasti lì che ha
aspettato la degenza si è esercitato ha
imparato a suonare la batteria in un
nuovo modo e dopo soli due anni nel 1986
ricche tornato sul palco del music hub
rock a donington con la sua band con la
sua famiglia con il def leppard è una
straordinaria storia di adattamento
dell'essere umano
def leppard sono una delle più grandi
band heavy metal hanno venduto oltre 100
milioni di dischi e adesso potete
comprare un loro disco alla base del
focus potenziante c'è la scienza i
neuroscienziati hanno condotto numerosi
esperimenti oggi sono in grado di dirci
come funziona il nostro cervello e
perché ragioniamo in un modo piuttosto
che in un altro quando noi ci
concentriamo esclusivamente sui nostri
limiti e sui nostri impedimenti
rilasciamo all'interno del nostro corpo
una sostanza nociva tossica e come la
kryptonite per superman si chiama
cortisolo l'ormone dello stress che ha
un impatto anche sul nostro organismo
sul nostro cuore sul battito cardiaco
sul respiro
questo avviene perché noi mettiamo in
relazione il nostro scopo il nostro
obiettivo con tutti i nostri limiti e
tutti i motivi per cui potremmo fallire
e in questo modo rilasciamo cortisolo
che crea la frustrazione che è dovuto
appunto dalla distanza incolmabile
questo dipende dal fatto che il cervello
il nostro cervello è qui per tenerci in
vita per proteggerci e se noi lo
bombardiamo in continuazione con e
questo non funziona e questo non ce lo
eccetera eccetera lui fa il suo mestiere
ci tiene in vita e allora ci dice cambia
strada e biologia funziona così ora è
chiaro che ognuno di noi quando progetto
a qualcosa deve tenere conto sia di
quello che non sa sia di quello che ha
ad esempio se io dovessi progettare una
vacanza e avessi soltanto hicks euro non
potè non potrei progettare una vacanza
dieci volte hicks questo è ovvio ma un
conto è focalizzarsi solo ed
esclusivamente sui propri limiti un
conto invece è giocare a favore del
proprio organismo farsi alleati i propri
limiti
perché vedete il punto non è fare
l'elenco esatto di tutto ciò che noi non
abbiamo ma il punto essere consapevoli
di quello che abbiamo per diventare
delle rockstar per andare dove vogliamo
ogni neuroscienziato ci dice che è
meglio avere nel nostro corpo delle
sostanze funzionali al nostro
obiettivo e per funzionare intendo che
tengano conto sia di quello che non
abbiamo che di quello che abbiamo quindi
la domanda è su cosa ponete il vostro
focus su quello che non avete o su
quello che avete su quello di cui non
avete il controllo o su quello di cui
avete il controllo vi faccio un altro
esempio questo mi è particolarmente
chiaro e sono molto affezionato a questo
esempio nel 1977 un ragazzo pubblica un
annuncio nella monte impulse col di
dublino vuole formare una band
rispondono alcuni ragazzi due sono
fratelli si chiamano dave e dic con la
particolarità che dick è leggermente più
bravo più virtuoso di dei entrano nella
band si esercitano fanno primi concerti
c'è un problema quello più bravo non è
molto sicuro di restare all'interno
della band perché un po è chiamato dalla
sua carriera accademica vuole studiare è
un po non è convinto che gli altri con
piani di viaggio siano così talentuosi
virtuosi non ha tutti i torti perché
loro non avevano mai preso in mano lo
strumento che poi sarebbe diventato lo
strumento di vita soltanto uno aveva
suonato per un po di tempo la batteria
allora dopo un po lascia quella band che
al tempo si chiamava hype poi ha
cambiato nome si sono chiamati feedback
e poi l'ultimo nome è quello con cui lo
conosciamo tutti i due allora il
fratello bravo lascia gli u2 per fondare
i virgin prunes gli altri quattro
ragazzi restano nella band e si
concentrano su quello che hanno invece
che concentrarsi sui loro limiti tecnici
si concentrano sul loro scopo volevano
occupare un posto nel mondo un posto
nella musica un posto nel rock allora
larry era l'unico che aveva mai suonato
la batteria diventa un metronomo diventa
sempre più puntuale paul ha una
grandissima presenza scenica una
grandissima voce passato alla storia col
soprannome di bono diventa il cantante
adam fortissimo nelle pubbliche
relazioni fa quello all'inizio della
band incomincia a trovare i primi
contatti primi concerti e che dire del
fratello meno bravo beh lui si è
concentrato sulla sua grandissima vena
artistica e sulla capacità di utilizzare
gli strumenti come nessun altro prima e
quindi
ma è trovato ha fondato ha sviluppato un
proprio timbro artistico innovativo e
oggi se tutti noi conosciamo le canzoni
degli u2
lo dobbiamo anche altri al timbro
musicale di di age questo il suo
soprannome che ha reso indimenticabili
le canzoni degli u2 che sono diventate
una delle più grandi rock band di tutti
i tempi hanno venduto oltre 200 milioni
di dischi hanno infranto tutti i record
in tutti i continenti e in ogni decennio
allora la domanda è su cosa di
focalizzate su quello che non avete o su
quello che avete su quello di cui non
avete il controllo su quello di cui
avete il controllo
ancora una volta la scienza ci viene in
aiuto ci dice qual è la strada
differente rispetto al cortisolo e la
frustrazione all'interno del nostro
corpo noi abbiamo delle sostanze che
sono dei nostri alleati ormoni e
sostanze che ci possono aiutare le
endorfine lo sito cina la serotonina un
neurotrasmettitore potentissimo alla
dopamina
quando noi mettiamo il vinile sul
giradischi della nostra rock band
preferita accade qualcosa all'interno
del nostro cervello il sistema
mesolimbico viene attivato dalle aree di
brodo mandia 44 b a 47 e rilasciano una
sostanza piacerà dopamina
questo ci permette di ottenere delle
performance migliori
stiamo meglio ci sentiamo bene è il
motivo per cui la musica è vietata nelle
competizioni agonistiche
sempre che voi non siate dei rocker mio
caso perché io mi concentro di più a
cantare su rocchi invece che sulla corsa
e quindi forse per d'un fiato di questa
è la spiegazione del le mie scarse doti
agonistiche ma questa è un'altra storia
quindi la biologia cosa ci dice la
biologia ci dice che all'interno del
nostro corpo noi possiamo dobbiamo
trovare la forza per riprogrammare il
nostro main set stare bene è una nostra
decisione
possiamo farlo abbiamo degli
interruttori ognuno di noi ne ha uno
all'interno del proprio corpo per far
scattare quello stato emotivo funzionale
per entrare nel mondo
delle rockstar nel mio caso il rock per
qualcun altro potrebbe essere la vela la
cucina alla pittura il volo qualunque
cosa dobbiamo conoscere qual è e
attivarla dobbiamo conoscere gli
interruttori della nostra felicità e
accenderli e quindi ancora una volta
qual è la domanda vera su cosa ponete il
vostro focus su quello che non avete o
su quello che avete su quello di cui non
avete il controllo su quello di cui
avete il controllo
il focus potenziante è un elemento
necessario ma non sufficiente
e ovvio che servono abilità competenze
studio esercizio preparazioni ultimi
soldi tante cose è necessario
assolutamente sì altrimenti saremmo
inefficienti potremmo anche raggiungere
il nostro obiettivo ma con molto più
sforzo molte più risorse oppure
rischiamo di essere inefficaci e non
raggiungere il nostro scopo
vincono i limiti
vi faccio un altro esempio ieri newman
tra i fondatori dell'onda new wave degli
anni 80 riconosciuto come figlio
artistico di david bowie coverizzato da
tantissime band famose nine in cinese e
tanti altri bene a gary ha 21 anni gli
viene diagnosticata una lieve forma di
autismo è affetto dalla sindrome di
asperger lui in quel momento calcava i
palchi bene incontrare gente e portare
le proprie emozioni su un palco
stringere le mani fare i firma copie e
farsi le foto con gli altri non è
compatibile con la condizione della
sindrome di asperger che invece porta ad
altro quindi gary avrebbe potuto reagire
diversamente ma non lo ha fatto ha
reagito nella maniera corretta
si è focalizzato su quello che aveva in
una recente intervista ha detto che è
grato alla sindrome di asperger perché
gli ha permesso di concentrarsi su
quello che aveva sulla propria arte
sulla propria musica e questo è
straordinario lo incita le altre persone
a non demoralizzarsi e anzi a fare leva
su quello che hanno e meraviglioso
quindi ancora una volta su cosa ponete
il vostro focus su quello che non avete
su quello che avete su quello di cui non
avete il controllo o su quello di cui
avete il controllo
qual è la sfida qual è la nostra sfida
oggi viviamo in un'epoca di accumulo e
ostentazione di tante cose
job title premi oggetti e follower e
cose
una costante ricerca quello che non
abbiamo non siamo mai contenti e questo
crea una perenne frustrazione io credo
che esista una strada differente opposta
la frustrazione mela indica il rock
questo è il motivo per il quale io ho
scelto le rockstar quali miei mentori le
rockstar sono persone normali accettano
la loro imperfezione e ci ballano sopra
essere normali è un atto eroico ognuno
di noi è una persona normale ognuno di
noi può essere un eroe come cantava deve
il bobby nel 77 con i rose just for one
day possiamo esserlo per una persona per
un giorno per un'azienda per un collega
per un cliente per chiunque per un
figlio essere normali vuol dire essere
rock perché coinvolgente quando noi
sentiamo una canzone stiamo bene quando
amiamo un concerto stiamo bene e quando
stiamo bene noi stanno bene anche le
persone che sanno di fianco a noi che
fanno parte del nostro mondo
ecco perché bono disse la musica può
cambiare il mondo perché può cambiare le
persone questo il motivo siamo
coinvolgenti quindi focalizzatevi su
quello che avete focalizzatevi su quello
di cui avete il controllo e tirate fuori
la rockstar che c'è in voi b e rockstar
grazie